il y en a pas deux comme ça il n'y a pas
deux comme ça et là vous avez je lis
franchement cette usine sera un jour la
première usine d'économie circulaire
dans l'automobile c'est la grande
ambition des dirigeants de renault
groupe autour de l'art factory le
basculement de l' usine de flins sur
seine vers un site d'économie circulaire
d'automobiles le premier pôle de ce
projet est déjà concrétisée avec la
factory vo un service de
reconditionnement de véhicules
d'occasion destiné aux concessionnaires
on a pour ça et l'implication qui qui
est relié au tout système d'information
de la factory puis nous affecte le la
rénovation de la véhicule en quelques
clics et choisit le niveau de prestation
qui veut pour son véhicule les time
complet pour ce process aujourd'hui dans
le réseau pérenne c'est à peu près 21
jours là nous on vise on lise dix jours
de bukavu et deux d'entre l'entrée du
procès c'est la photo ce qui est le
moment de la mise en vente c'est plutôt
huit jours dès l'arrivée de la voiture
sur site le process de rénovation
commence par une série de diagnostic sur
l'état du véhicule regarde c'est pas des
anomalies ou des câbles qui sont
débranchés ou
tout autre état de détérioration en fin
de compte et s'ils s'étaient détériorées
par on en voit ça pour la mécanique pour
faire l'appareil remettrai véhicule en
état vient ensuite la partie concrète du
reconditionnement sur quatre lignes le
site est organisé comme une usine de
montage avec les différentes étapes à
partir du diagnostic les réparations
sont réalisés si vous voyez là le
matricule de la voiture qui vient de
rentrer je croise celle là bas il ya le
filtrage filtre à air et liquide de fra
et tout ce qui a à faire il faut qui
suit tout ça et après lé coach ce qu'il
a fait pour vraiment la voiture et et
les suédoises du ska qui se dore tuschi
affaires et même les commentaires si on
voit quelque chose on passe commentaires
pour l'autre collet qui va prendre la
suite
[Musique]
oh
la suite c'est la carrosserie la
peinture les contrôles qualité et
techniques avant un essai routier des
photographies sont réalisées à envoyer
aux concessionnaires pour la vente du
véhicule 1500 véhicules ont déjà été
reconditionnée depuis le mois de
septembre l'objectif est fixé à 45 mille
véhicules par an et nous sommes avec
jean-philippe bilahi le directeur de
l'ars factory bonjour bonjour alors ça y
est c'est lancé depuis septembre un
facteur humain est depuis septembre ça
fait en fait le projet de cette factory
vo on l'a lancé fin décembre et je
dirais en un temps record en
septembre on était déjà en montée en
cadence
dans ce bâtiment aujourd'hui combien de
personnes travaillent dans la route
factory aujourd'hui on a environ 150
personnes qui travaillent sur la factory
vo alors l'arrêt factory c'est le projet
global et factory vo la gérer et un sous
projet du projet aurait factory alors il
ya la factory vo quels sont les trois
autres projets de l'art factory alors
effectivement la factory vo c'est l'inde
est une des grosses activités de notre
activité de retrofit ensuite on est en
train de lancer un ensemble d'activités
sur le pôle reenergy qui vise enfin le
point de départ de cette activité c'est
finalement les batteries qui sont
aujourd'hui dans chez nos clients dans
leurs voitures qui vont nous revenir en
fin de vie et pour lequel on va on est
en train de développer des activités de
réutilisation seconde vie
le troisième pôle série cycl ou là on
veut réutiliser les pièces issues des
voitures en fin de vie donc déconstruire
les voitures récupérer les pièces et les
réutiliser ensuite pour reconditionner
des véhicules d'occasion et puis le
dernier pôle c'est finalement sur la
plaie restart c'est de faire de flins un
centre d'innovation un dernier mot
l'inquiétude ici c'est l'inquiétude des
salariés qui ont peur de perdre leur
emploi aujourd'hui vous assurer que
finalement les emplois seront maintenus
au moins il y aura un accompagnement
pour une transition absolument
aujourd'hui on a en visibilité de 1 sur
grâce au projet riz factory d'assurer un
emploi à tous les collaborateurs de
lusine au moment où le véhicule à la
fabrication de voitures s'arrêtera donc
on a annoncé me 2024
[Musique]
ici on est en train de développer un
projet assez innovant assez unique et
qui nous permettra déjà de voilà de
donner une nouvelle vie à cette usine
glorieuse auquel on tient à beaucoup et
aussi ça nous permettra de comprendre le
ciel de vraiment du business dans
l'économie circulaire c'est un système
ouvert parce qu'on a envie d'inviter les
autres entreprises à investir sur
l'économie circulaire pour comprendre
que l'inspection les connexions quel est
le business potentiel on est en train
d'organiser un accélérateur de start up
pour permettre aux jeunes aux petites
entreprises de venir et coopérer avec
nous on est en train de développer le
concept de l'arno university donc de
former des gens
ici donc de faire une université de
l'économie circulaire
[Musique]